des mesures radicales face à
l'insécurité le président félix
tshisekedi avait prévenu dans la soirée
de vendredi c'est son porte parole qu'il
a annoncé le président de la république
a informé le conseil des ministres de sa
décision de proclamer conformément à
l'article 85 de la constitution un état
de siège dans les provinces du nord kivu
et de l'ituri
une décision motivée par la présence de
dizaines de vous armés actifs dans l'est
de la rdc
il s'agit notamment des adf forces
démocratiques alliées des rebelles
musulmans ougandais à l'origine qui
seraient coupables du massacre de plus
de 1000 civils depuis novembre 2019
sur le seul territoire de béni une
mesure sage pour certains mais qui
soulève également de nombreuses
interrogations
la décision du chef de l'état elle va
notamment dans l'intérêt de la
population et si elle va faire revenir
la province du kivu et en ituri partout
en rdc
et donc c'est une bonne décision et
qu'elle peut être est elle peut être
populaire
mais elle revient ils vont décision du
fait qu'il est va aider et conformément
à ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état elle
amélie nice et à contrôler la question
sécuritaire la population ici au nord
kivu se pose beaucoup de questions vous
savez ce qu'il dit est à dire qui a qui
aura beaucoup de restrictions au niveau
de la population et au niveau de toute
la province il ya l'administration qui
ne va plus être la même
les autorités ne vont plus être les
mêmes la population sait qu'elle a une
armée des gens qui se sacrifie ma parmi
ces gens-là de l'armée il ya des
affairistes des gens qui font du
commerce des véhicules du commerce lors
du commerce du bois de commerce du cacao
etc autant de questions que nous nous
posons est ce que le chef de l'état a pu
mourir vraiment cette décision des
inquiétudes conforté par les récentes
manifestations de rejet de la mission de
l'organisation des nations unies en
république démocratique du congo la
monusco par la population de béni qui
l'accusent d'inaction face à ces tueries
vendredi matin après une semaine de
siège devant la mairie la police a
dispersé un sit-in d'étudiants qui
réclamaient également la présence du
président
en parallèle à ce mécontentement félix
tshisekedi a lui été conforté par sa
visite à paris ce mardi où il a demandé
l'aide de la france dans mon pays la
république démocratique du congo à l'est
où il s'est créé y ait maintenant un
groupe à tendance islamiste au discours
islamiste et aux méthodes islamistes et
qui sèment la terreur auprès de nos
populations
donc là je suis plus que jamais
déterminé à l'éradiquer et je compte sur
le soutien de la france
mais l'état de siège signifie aussi le
remplacement de l'administration civile
par l'administration militaire
une ordonnance doit bientôt détailler
les modalités d'application de cet état
de siège